>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WHERE WE PIT TWO
NEWS PROFESSIONALS AGAINST
ONE ANOTHER TO SEE WHICH OF
THEM HAS BEEN PAYING CLOSER
ATTENTION.
HEAVY HITTERS THIS WEEK.
A FOX MAIN STAY AGAINST ONE
OF HIS FREQUENT GUESTS BRET
BAIER ONE OF THE BEST
INFORMED NEWS ANCHOR IN
WASHINGTON HOSTS "SPECIAL
REPORT."
MOLLIE HEMMING WAY.
MASTER SENIOR EDITOR AT THE
FEDERALIST.
TODAY THEY MAKE TODAY'S
CONTESTANTS, WELCOME.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
DO YOU KNOW HOW NERVOUS WE
ARE COLLECTIVELY?
>> NOT GOOD.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT GOING TO
TELL WHO I GET ON.
YOU KNOW THE RULES.
I WILL REPEAT THEM.
I ASK THE QUESTIONS.
FIRST ONE BUZZ IN ANSWER.
FINISH UNTIL I ASK THE
QUESTION BEFORE YOU DO THAT
EVERY RIGHT QUESTION ONE
POINT.
GET ONE WRONG LOSE A POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
READY?
>> Bret: READY.
>> Tucker: FERGIE, THE
SINGER UPSET A LOT OF PEOPLE
JAZZY RENDITION BEING
GENEROUS, AT WHICH GAME DID
THAT PERFORMANCE TAKE PLACE?
BRET BAIER.
>> FERGIE SANG AT THE
BASKETBALL GAME.
>> Tucker: ALMOST THERE.
>> AT THE BASKETBALL GAME
NOW.
>> Tucker: WE ARE GOING TO
ROLL THE TAPE.
>> I THOUGHT YOU NEEDED
SPECIFIC GAME.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT THE
JUDGE.
>> I HAD A GOOD ANSWER.
>> Tucker: GET MORE
SPECIFIC?
>> NO, NO.
LET'S JUST ROLL THE TAPE.
>> Tucker: LET'S ROLL THE
TAPE.
BASKETBALL GAME.
>> GOOD THING IS EVERYONE
STOOD IF HE BASKETBALL GAME
NBA ALL STAR GAME.
SOME COULDN'T STAND WHAT
THEY WERE HEARING.
♪ O SAY DOES THAT STAR
SPANGLED
STANGLED
STARGLED
STAR-SED
STAR-SPANGLED BANNER YET
WAVE.
>> Tucker: SOUNDS LIKE A
SOBER JANICE JOPLIN.
>> Bret: I MEANT ALL STAR.
>> Tucker: I'M GOING TO ASK
THEM NOW IS BASKETBALL GAME
ADEQUATE?
>> NO.
[BUZZER] BRIAN.
>> Bret: I GET A MINUS?
MOLLY: THAT SEEMS UNFAIR.
>> Tucker: APPLE IS MOVING
ITS EMPLOYEES INTO A 5
BILLION-DOLLAR SHAYSSHIP
LIKE CAMPUS BUT THE GLASS
WALLS ARE CAUSING A PAINFUL
PROBLEM FOR ITS WORKERS.
WHAT IS THAT PROBLEM?
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY?
>> THIS BREAKS MY STRATEGY.
YOU ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO
ANSWER IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER.
I'M JUST GOING TO GO WITH
GLARE.
>> Tucker: GLARE, IS IT
GLARE?
>> THE NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES
WALKING INTO THE CURVED
GLASS WALLS THERE HAS GOTTEN
SO BAD EMERGENCY SERVICES
HAD TO BE CALLED.
WORKERS ARE SAYING HEY, WE
ARE GOING TO PUT STICKY
NOTES ON SOME OF THESE GLASS
WALLS AND DOORS SO PEOPLE
DON'T WALK INTO THEM.
APPARENTLY REPORTEDLY THEIR
BOSSES TOOK THE STICKY NOTES
OFF BECAUSE IT RUINED THE
DESIGN AND THE LOOK OF THE
BUILDING.
>> Bret: SO THEY ARE LIKE
BIRDS?
>> Tucker: THEY ARE LIKE
YOUR CAT, YEAH.
THEY RUN RIGHT INTO IT.
[BUZZER]
FIRST TIME IN THE 35 YEAR
HISTORY OF THIS SHOW OR
THREE MONTHS, HOWEVER LONG
IT'S BEEN, WE HAVE A TIE OF
NEGATIVE ONE TO NEGATIVE
ONE.
>> I WANT TO SEE HOW LOW WE
CAN GO.
>> Tucker: ALL YOUR FEARS
ARE TRUE.
MONSTER IN THE CLOSET.
AFTER A 20-YEAR DROUGHT
WHICH WOMEN'S OLYMPIC TEAM
BROUGHT HOME THE GOLD TODAY
AFTER A POST MATCH AGAINST
CANADA?
>> CANNED?
>> MOLLIE HELPING WAY YOU
BUZZED EARLY.
>> U.S. WOMEN'S HOCKEY TEAM
AGAINST CANADA.
[CHEERS]
>> GOLD MEDAL WINNING HOCKEY
PLAYERS ARE IN THE HOUSE.
HI, YOU GUYS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT'S BETTER
THAN A GOLD MEDAL?
23 GOLD MEDALS.
>> Tucker: SO THE GOOD NEWS
IS YOU ARE WINNING.
BAD NEWS YOU ARE AT ZERO
ANYWAY.
>> IT'S ALL RELATIVE.
>> Tucker: ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE THE
FASTEST.
YOU CAN'T BE THE SLOWEST.
WHICH HOLLYWOOD ACTRESS
ANNOUNCED THIS WEEK SHE WILL
BE GIVING UP HER ACTING FOR
A YEAR TO FOCUS ON FIXING
OUR DEMOCRACY?
BRET BAIER?
>> JENNIFER LAWRENCE.
>> Tucker: NOT AWARE OF HER
AS AN ACTRESS BUT WE WILL
SEE IF YOU ARE CORRECT.
JENNIFER LAWRENCE IS THE
ANSWER.
ROLL THE TAPE, PLEASE.
>> SHE HAS A BIG NEW MOVIE
COMING OUT AT THE BOX OFFICE
BUT JENNIFER LAWRENCE WON'T
BE ACTING ANYMORE FOR A
WHILE BECAUSE SHE HAS
DECIDED TO BECOME A
FULL-TIME ACTIVIST.
>> STATE-BY-STATE LAWS THAT
CAN HELP PREVENT CORRUPTION,
FIX OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: SO NOW THAT SHE
IS NO LONGER GOING TO BE
DOING MOVIES WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO ON THE WEEKENDS,
BRIAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT GOOD AT
MATH SO I DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE ARE.
THIS IS THE FINAL QUESTION.
ARE YOU READY?
IT GOES FAST ON THIS SHOW.
JAWS DROPPED AS THE LONDON
FASHION WEEK AFTER A VERY
IMPORTANT PERSON, A FAMOUS
ONE SENT TO VOGUE EDITOR
ALSO IMPORTANT AND FAMOUS.
PEOPLE ARE UPSET WITH HER
FOR NOT TAKING OFF HER
SUNGLASSES OR EVEN CALLING
HER DISRESPECTFUL.
WHO IS THE HEAD OF STATE WHO
SAT NEXT TO HER?
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY?
>> WHAT'S THE QUEEN?
>> Tucker: QUEEN OF.
>> ELIZABETH.
>> Tucker: QUEEN ELIZABETH?
>> YES.
>> Tucker: IS IT QUEEN
ELIZABETH.
>> QUEEN ELIZABETH NEVER
WAIVERRED IN FASHION SENSE.
MAKING FASHION WEEKDAY BUOY
ON TUESDAY SITTING NEXT TO
THE GRAND DAM OF ALL THINGS
STYLISH.
BRITISH DESIGNER RICHARD
QUINN'S RUNWAY SHOW.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE RIGHT.
JUDGES JUST SAID IF IT
WEREN'T FOR THAT TECHNICAL
ERROR WE MIGHT HAVE A TIE
RIGHT NOW.
WE WOULD BE IN TIE BREAKING
TERRITORY AND YOU HAVE TO
GUESS THE CAPITAL OF